nous allons maintenant parler de la
chanson nazima c'est une chanson que
vous avez probablement déjà entendu
puisqu'elle fait partie d'un album celui
de france gall intitulé babacar un album
qui est sorti au ça fait presque deux
ans 80 au moins au moins deux ans alors
et on procède foot et expliquer ça à
ceux qui nous écoutent et nous regardent
comment on procède quand on a un album
donc ça fait quoi 12 cents sont à peu
près aussi peu à souligner un jeu à
peine le dire ça fait 9 9 c'est pourquoi
non mais c'est pas ce que parce que
cette fois ci c'est une volonté d'avoir
des chansons un peu plus long pour
pouvoir dire on évoluera ensuite pour
accompagner ses chansons d'un club où et
quand il ya maintenant c'est à dire
pourquoi on fait savoir
et bien parce que maintenant le clip est
pratiquement indispensable comme ça
immédiat ce que je veux dire on le camp
la chanson sort on ne fait pas ce qu'il
va aimer les français n'ont d'abord ce
qu'on peut faire le clip qu'une fois que
la chanson est fait et puis c'est long
de faire un clip ça prend au moins trois
semaines
à moins d'être sûr que c'est un petit
film un petit mais ça peut quand même
c'est beaucoup de monde d une production
enfin c'est pour tromper de chansons
parce qu'on va pas faire raquer pour
chaque mois j'ai pratiquement effet 5
sur cet album
et cette chanson était derrière
évidemment en troisième simple il est
ressorti la maintenant parce que je
trouvais dommage de la voir
pourquoi on la regarde
dans leurs souvenirs
chasseurs et des larmes
mr
de sa poule
et m
l'antre de toi
d'emblée d'une vente
non mais toi qui viens fin où l'on
oublie qu'on boit dealer ce que tu
penses dealer ce que tu vois dealers des
leurs jean d'amour qui peu après 6h
d'animer abéché bon c'est une histoire
l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui vous
écrit le plus explique moi c'est une
lettre imaginaire avec michel berger
dans votre univers high street après un
premier voyage qu'on a fait ou au mali
en 86 et on avait rencontré là-bas des
touareg évidemment et ce jeune touareg
azima et bon michel a écrit cette lettre
imaginaire et quand il est retourné
faire le clip on a retrouvé bien sûr et
et on a fait il a tourné cette histoire
et cette azim a lui-même qui fait le
rôle du petit garçon mais tient
incroyablement grandi où la muba revue
un hymne à vous nous avons découvert
avec le film ou de deux trois ans il a
beaucoup de chances d'aller en afrique
pour des raisons humanitaires qu'on
apprenne mamadou je n'avais jamais en
afrique en vacances sa phrase alcine je
sais que c'est un pays magnifique
merveilleux mais je ne peux pas aller en
afrique en vacances parce que c'est un
pays qui souffre trop et tombouctou qui
est une ville extraordinaire quand on a
été une fois à tombouctou on peut plus
oublier cette ville ce qu'elle est
absolument unique dont vous tous qui
était une ville florissante maintenant
et oeuvrent au lion au centre du désert
est complètement touché par la
désertification et les jambes heures
dans la rue maintenant et c'est affreux
d'où cette lettre de sa cible cela dit
on pour trouver un point commun
votre démarche artistique là c'est
souvent en faveur des enfants j'ai
remarqué à autre chose rui priorité bon
puis c'est ce qui me touche le plus
aussi bien dans la médecine dans l'est
dans la recherche sur les maladies
génétiques ou oui les enfants je trouve
ça toujours des gens importants est
inadmissible que les enfants souffrent
et meurent comme ce petit garçon en
début de journal insulte intolérable et
en plus c'est je veux dire je sais que
ça arrive pas très très souvent mais ça
arrive souvent un cas comme ce petit
garçon oui voilà alors pour cette raison
là et pour d'autres vous serez toujours
la bienvenue
merci de votre de votre visite et la
chanson d'asie ma je ne sais pas si je
vais l'éthique c'est en 45 tours
maintenant vous êtes vous vous êtes là
voilà sept ans 45 tours